on a en martin et tous les éléments
nécessaires pour réaliser un café
d'excellentes nous allons impliquer les
jeunes pour qu'ils connaissent la
filière café qui puisse la développer
demain
je suis pilote du projet café et on a
proposé aux différents établissements
scolaires du premier degré jusqu'aux
études supérieures de participer à cette
belle aventure puisque la transat
jacques vabre c'est là où la route du
café ça passe par la réalisation par
exemple de café gourmand ça passe par
deux des courses de garçons de café ça
passe par la valorisation de déchets
textiles pour réaliser du sac cabas ça
passe par un cocktail dînatoire
autour du café dont on a par exemple des
jeunes qui vont proposer des produits
cosmétiques à base de café et des
produits alimentaires
c'est une très grande chance pour la
martinique de recevoir la transat
jacques vabre et à nous de faire ce
qu'il faut pour la garder